This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Neil.
This is the programme where in just 6 minutes we discuss an interesting topic
and teach some related English vocabulary.
Enjoying me to do this is Rob.
Hello. Sorry, Neil. How long did you say this programme is?
6 minutes. It's 6 Minute English, Rob.
Right. Okay. Sorry. What's your name again?
Neil. My name's Neil, Rob. What's happened to your memory?
Sorry, Neil. Too many things on my mind. It's affecting my short-term memory.
But what I can remember is that in this programme we're talking about improving our memory.
We are, and I think you might find it quite useful.
Storing information is an important function of our brains and scientists are always looking at ways
to improve it, but also to stop it deteriorating or becoming worse.
Yes. And we all know that memories, that's the noun for things we remember from the past,
are nice to have, but also important for remembering who people are,
where things are kept and how things look.
Soon we'll be discussing a new idea for improving your memory, but not before I've set today's
quiz question. There are many ways we can improve our memory, but one way is through the type of
food we eat. According to the BBC Food website, which type of food supports good memory function?
Is it a, eggs, b, spinach or sea bananas?
Well, as a kid I was always told that spinach was good for me, pop I ate it to make him strong,
so I'll say b, spinach.
Well, I'll have the answer later on.
Now let's talk more about improving our memory. Memory is the ability to encode,
recall information, but a number of factors can affect people's memory processes,
including health, anxiety, mood, stress and tiredness.
That's why, for example, if you're taking an exam, it's important to get a good night's sleep
and to keep healthy. But Neil, when you're revising for an exam, what helps you to remember facts?
I tend to write things down again and again and again and again.
Ah, well, that's one way, but people have different styles to help them remember.
According to the BBC's iWonderGuide, there are three different styles,
visual, auditory and kinesthetic. That's learning by doing and practicing something over and over again.
That sounds like me.
But recently a new study has come up with a method that could possibly be the best way to improve
your memory, and that's by drawing. Darryl O'Connor, whose professor of psychology at the University
of Leeds has been speaking about it on the BBC Radio 4 program all in the mind.
See if you can work out why.
The authors certainly argue that one of the things that happens is by drawing these particular objects
that it leads to this increased contextual representation of the object in one's mind.
It makes a lot of intuitive sense, the idea that if you have encoded something in a greater
level of detail, it's like you're more likely to remember it. It's much stronger than just
remembering that writing down the words.
Okay, so let's try to explain that. Drawing something leads to increased contextual
representation of the object, but something is contextual. It is in the situation where it usually
exists. So as you draw something, you're creating a picture in your mind about what it is,
how you use it, and where it's used. I wonder if this means artists have good memories.
Maybe Darryl O'Connor says that when you draw, you are encoding something in a greater level
of detail, more than you would by just writing things down. Encoding is changing information into
a form that can be stored and later recalled. That's because as you draw, you're thinking about
different aspects of the object. He says it makes intuitive sense. Intuitive means it's based on
feelings rather than facts or proof, so you just feel it's the best thing to do. Of course,
this is just one more way to improve your memory. I have also heard that doing crossword puzzles and
Sudoku can help, especially when you're older. Yes, as we get older, we can often have more difficulty
retrieving information from our memory, and people with Alzheimer's find it very difficult to
encode information. So anyway, to keep our memory working is a good thing. Basically, we need
brain training. Brain training and eating the right food, Rob. You might remember that earlier I
asked you, according to the BBC Food website, which type of food supports good memory function?
Is it a, eggs, b, spinach or c, bananas? And Rob, you said, I do remember and I said b, spinach.
And that is sort of the wrong answer. In fact, they were all correct. They are all examples of food
that can help support good memory. Apparently, foods rich in b vitamins are important as they provide
protection for the brain as we age and support good memory function. I think it's time to change my
diet. Now, once in the vocabulary we looked at in this program. So today we've been talking about
our memory. We use our memory to remember things and memories is the noun for things we remember
from the past. Then we discussed a learning style known as kinesthetic, that is learning by doing
and practicing something over and over again. We heard from Professor Darryl O'Connor who talked
about contextual representation. When something is contextual, you see it in the situation where it
usually exists. Next, we talked about encoding, that is, changing information into a form that can
be stored and later recalled. And we mentioned intuitive sense. Having an intuitive sense means doing
something based on feelings rather than facts or proof. So you just feel it's the best thing to do.
And finally, we mentioned Alzheimer's, a disease affecting the brain that makes it difficult to
remember things and it gets worse as you get older. Well, there are lots of new words to remember
there, but that's all for this program. Don't forget to visit us on Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram and YouTube and our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com. Bye for now. Goodbye.